one thing writers hate to do is write
take moss heart he said so last year it
was a 400 page book called act one
he's here tonight to give out the
writer's award and in very good company
with his wife and if any of you think
she looks like kitty carlisle you're
mighty close will the real mr and mrs
moss heart please step forward
thank you
it's always gratifying to be part of any
proceeding where a writer is going to
get something
instead of getting in the neck as usual
from the critics
kitty will you read the nomination
nominated for the best screenplay based
on material from another medium are
richard brooks elmer gantry nathan e
douglas and harold jacob smith inherit
the wind
gavin lambert and t e clarke
sons and lovers
isabelle leonard
the sundowners
and james kennaway
tunes of glory
i am delighted to read the name of the
winner
the winner
richard brooks
the bible says it first came the word
uh
but probably before the word there was
an idea or a concept in case of elmer
gantry uh that belongs to sinclair lewis
so many other people to thank that i
don't have the time so why don't we do
this again thank you